hace varios vídeos demostramos que sí
tenemos una placa infinita uniformemente
cargada entonces el campo eléctrico que
genera es constante por ejemplo si esta
es una placa infinita uniformemente
cargada con carga positiva entonces su
campo eléctrico se vería como flechitas
hacia arriba y todas de la misma
magnitud que no importa donde estén
todas de la misma magnitud y además
vimos cómo encontrar el campo eléctrico
el campo eléctrico el campo eléctrico
está estaba dado por dos veces la
constante de colom por pi por sigma
donde sigma era la densidad de carga y
platicamos acerca de ese sigma en el
vídeo en el cual demostramos que el
campo eléctrico era constante y dijimos
que sigma no era nada más que la carga
total por el área total ahora hay un
poquito de problemas utilizando esta
definición de sigma cuando la placa es
infinita
sí porque entonces la el área total
sería infinita y la carga total también
tendría que ser infinita para que esto
nos quedara pues un número entonces
ahorita vamos a pensar en placas
y lo bonito de las placas finitas es que
estando cerca de su centro se comportan
casi como una placa infinita o sea
tienen campos eléctricos casi constantes
y así bueno con estas ideas vamos a ver
si podemos encontrar alguna relación
entre el voltaje y la carga cuando
tenemos dos placas paralelas de la
siguiente forma déjame hacer el dibujo
para que quede bien claro a qué me
refiero entonces voy a tener dos placas
paralelas
aquí voy a tener una abajo y esta le voy
a poner carga positiva y voy a poner una
segunda placa aquí arriba vale entonces
esa segunda placa la voy a poner color
naranja y vamos a pensar que tiene carga
negativa tiene carga negativa muy bien
entonces pregunta cómo se ve el campo
eléctrico de ambas placas o sea si
juntas bueno pues tendríamos que ver
cuál es la carga de cada una de ellas ya
qué distancia están pero más o menos la
idea general es que es la combinación de
los campos eléctricos de las dos va
vamos a ver cómo como podemos pensar en
eso
para esto déjame poner que la de acá
abajo tiene carga q y vamos a pensar que
la de arriba tiene la misma magnitud de
carga sólo que negativa entonces tendría
carga menos q
y además voy a ponerle aquí que la
distancia entre estas dos es de vale y
vamos a suponer que de no es muy grande
si de no es muy grande pues
prácticamente cerca del centro de estas
placas vamos a tener un campo eléctrico
constante y entonces se vería más o
menos de esta forma la placa de abajo
tiene su propio campo eléctrico que
tiene unas ciertas flechitas hacia
arriba así entonces cerca del centro las
flechitas van hacia arriba bueno por
todas partes van hacia arriba pero cerca
del centro parece constante las
flechitas van hacia arriba porque
acuérdate que ponemos una carga positiva
de prueba para ver para dónde van las
flechas aquí se alejan entonces aquí es
casi constante casi constante pero
cuando nos acercamos a la orilla se
empieza se empieza a enfocar un poco
igual para acá es casi constante casi
constante para acá a kiss en chueca un
poco ya casa en chueca más
vale entonces eso de ahí es el campo
eléctrico de la de abajo cómo se vería
el campo eléctrico de la de arriba pues
también serían flechitas y hacia dónde
van van otra vez hacia arriba porque si
ponemos una carga positiva
digamos por aquí entonces esta carga
positiva es atraída hacia la placa
entonces una vez más tenemos flechitas
hacia arriba vale entonces el campo
eléctrico también son flechitas hacia
arriba que cerca del centro parecen
implícitas constantes pero cuando nos
acercamos a la orilla vuelven a
enfocarse misma idea para acá misma idea
para acá
muy bien entonces ahí tenemos la
flechita entonces básicamente la idea es
que tenemos el doble de campo eléctrico
porque estamos juntando este con este
pero esos dos son iguales porque este
bueno va para arriba va para arriba pero
éste también va para arriba porque ahora
la carga de ésta es negativa vale bueno
entonces queremos ver la una bueno
alguna relación entre el voltaje de ir
de este punto de acá a este punto de acá
y la distancia de las placas y su área
es quizás la carga que pongamos va
entonces como lo vamos a hacer
pues vamos a empezar calculando el campo
eléctrico de cada una de estas y luego
el campo eléctrico total y luego
usaremos kulon para ver la fuerza y
todas esas cosas entonces déjame empezar
poniendo el campo eléctrico de la de
aquí abajo y el campo eléctrico
voy a poner un color voy a poner el
color de esta misma entonces el campo
eléctrico el campo eléctrico está dado
por esta expresión de acá
2k pin 2 por acá por pi por sigma pero
en vez de poner sigma voy a poner q / a
/ porque tenemos esta carga y vamos a
pensar que tienen área a vale las dos
tienen tarea para ahora vamos con la de
acá arriba cuál sería el campo eléctrico
acá el campo eléctrico sería igual a 2 k
2 si le puse a ver 2 acá y por aquí no
vamos a poner menos q porque si bueno
aunque aunque la carga que tenemos aquí
es menos q tenemos que el campo
eléctrico va hacia arriba entonces si
nos fijamos bueno con qué magnitud va
hacia arriba entonces es q
/ a entonces en ambos casos tenemos que
el campo eléctrico es de 2 katy porque
entre a y la dirección del campo
eléctrico es para arriba entonces cuál
sería el campo eléctrico ya combinado
déjame llamarle a este el campo
eléctrico 2 ya este campo eléctrico 1 y
por lo tanto el campo eléctrico
combinado ya el mero mero causado por
ambas placas sería igual a la suma de
estos dos entonces son igualitos verdad
nada más y juntamos este con este y nos
quedaría 4 k
/ / / a muy bien ya vamos avanzando
hacia determinar la diferencia de
voltaje y bueno para acordarnos que era
estos de diferencia de voltaje pues era
la diferencia de energía potencial
eléctrica pero por carga entre este
punto de acá y este punto de acá
entonces vamos a encontrar el voltaje
digamos
en este punto de acá con respecto a este
por qué pues porque justo una partícula
que está aquí tiene mucha energía
potencial eléctrica verdad porque quiere
subir tiene muchas ganas de ir hacia
arriba entonces bueno que tantas ganas
tiene de ir pues dependen depende de qué
tanto trabajo nos costó bajarla va
entonces vamos a encontrar el trabajo
por la ley de culo bueno aquí vamos a
poner una carga positiva aunque en la
vida real usualmente lo que se mueve ya
en los circuitos son los electrones que
son las negativas pero bueno pensamos
que es una carga positiva y pensemos en
su voltaje que prácticamente es cuántas
ganas tiene de llegar a este lado de por
acá o sea no sé a lo mejor aquí hay aire
y entonces no puede irse para allá pero
si ponemos un cable pues ya va a querer
irse para allá muy rápido entonces
podemos pensar en el voltaje más o menos
como como la presión eléctrica así como
cuando en agua uno habla de presión aquí
en electricidad se habla de voltaje va
quizás después debería hablar un poco
más de voltaje en otro vídeo para ganar
una mayor intuición porque es muy
importante estudiar la intuición
el voltaje sobre todo si quieres
estudiar una ingeniería eléctrica pero
bueno ya me estoy perdiendo regresemos
al problema entonces ya tenemos nuestro
nuestro campo eléctrico que es el campo
eléctrico total y queremos determinar la
energía potencial eléctrica de una
partícula que esté aquí
o lo que es lo mismo el trabajo de mover
una partícula positiva de aquí acá va
después vamos a hacerlo por carga para
que nos dé el voltaje pero comenzando
por el trabajo comenzando por el trabajo
que necesitamos hacer digamos para bajar
una una partícula de carga un culo el
trabajo que tenemos que hacer es la
fuerza eléctrica que hay que
contrarrestar que sería un culo por el
campo eléctrico si hasta ahorita esto de
aquí nada más es la fuerza la carga por
el campo eléctrico y esto lo tendríamos
que multiplicar por la distancia que
estamos recorriendo va entonces cuánto
sería esto pues esto es
el campo eléctrico por la distancia
lluís creo que no podemos decir nada más
por el momento entonces es el campo por
la distancia lluís muy bien esto de aquí
es el trabajo que necesitamos para bajar
la partícula entonces eso de ahí sería
la energía potencial eléctrica pero nos
interesa la diferencia de potencial
eléctrico digamos entre este punto de
acá vamos a llamarle a este punto de acá
p y la voy a poner con otro color un
poco más brillante con con este color
rosa
entonces lo que nos interesa es la
diferencia de potencial eléctrico entre
el punto y el punto b y esa es igual al
trabajo que realizamos pero por carga
vale entonces esto sería igual a por b o
sea aquí arriba fue una carga de un
coulombe entonces nada tenemos que
dividir entre 1 entonces otra vez nos
quedaría el borde pero ojo ya no son
jules sino volts volts entonces estoy
aquí sería el voltaje vale entonces la
diferencia de potencial eléctrico sería
igual a esta expresión de acá que
podemos reescribir la sí podemos
ponerle que la diferencia de voltaje es
igual a y aquí vamos a poner en vez del
campo eléctrico lo que encontramos del
campo eléctrico es igual a 4
y
bueno el q lo voy a dejar hasta acá de /
/ a
/ / a por por q va entonces aquí ya
tenemos al voltaje en términos de la
carga déjame poner ahora a la carga en
términos del voltaje entonces la carga
la carga es igual a tenemos que pasar
esto dividiendo del otro lado entonces
sería igual a a
entre 4 cada
y de por
por el voltaje vale entonces aquí bueno
ya tenemos una relación padre dos
relaciones padres que nos relacionan
voltaje con carga y están padres por qué
pues porque bueno pensando en que el
área es constante que tiene bastante
sentido y que la distancia entre las
placas es constante
tenemos que existe una relación
directamente proporcional entre la carga
y el voltaje eso está bonito o sea no es
algo que tuviéramos de entrada a lo
mejor la carga era directamente
proporcional al cuadrado del voltaje o a
la raíz pero ahora sabemos que no ahora
sabemos que es una relación directamente
proporcional bueno otra cosa interesante
es este coeficiente de aquí si este
coeficiente y este coeficiente de acá a
este coeficiente se le conoce como
capacidad eléctrica entonces otra forma
de escribir a la capacidad eléctrica
desde la siguiente forma q entrevé q / b
es igual
ar
y lo voy a poner así me lo voy a poner
como 1 entre 4
y
por a internet
ahora entre de va entonces para una
cierta configuración de área y de
distancia de área de las placas y de
distancia entre ellas a través de este
coeficiente que es la capacidad
eléctrica podemos conocer la relación
entre la carga y el voltaje podemos
conocer el voltaje si nos dan la carga y
viceversa
bueno las unidades de capacidad
eléctrica son los salarios le voy a
poner por aquí para dios
adiós y si estudias algo relacionado con
electricidad seguro te vas a topar con
ellos a cada rato y otra cosa bonita es
este término este término de acá a este
término también se le conoce como como
épsilon o como el filón cero
y se le llama la permití vida del
espacio o bien la permití vida del vacío
después vamos a platicar un poco más
acerca de eso porque ahorita ya me pasé
muchísimo del tiempo entonces nada más
un pequeño resumen si tenemos una carga
podemos calcular el voltaje de este
capacitor ah por cierto esto se llama
capacitor entonces si tenemos una carga
podemos calcular el voltaje de este
capacitor y eso nos da pues una idea de
la presión eléctrica que existe o sea de
que tantas ganas tenemos de movernos de
este punto a a este punto a este punto b
si tuviéramos una forma de movernos vale
o sea si pusiéramos un cable entonces
las cosas se empezarían a fluir y
generaríamos una corriente después vamos
a platicar de eso pero bueno además dada
una configuración de área y de distancia
tenemos una cierta capacidad eléctrica y
a través de esa capacidad eléctrica
podemos conocer o bien el voltaje con la
carga o bien la carga con el voltaje
bueno nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo